labège bonjour alors est ce que le
cortège de cette manifestation est
partie et quelle est l'ambiance sur
place
bah écoutez vous l'entendez peut-être
samantha l'ambiance et et joyeuse et
plutôt cordiale alors ils sont quelques
centaines de salariés de la poste avoir
répondu à cette invitation des
principaux syndicats du groupe donc cgt
fo et sud
est ce qu'ils réclament c'est une
revalorisation salariale
l'arrêt des suppressions de postes et
des fermetures de bureaux ainsi que la
mise en place d'un plan d'embauché
massif
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
manifestants on voit bien que malgré
tous les efforts qui ont été faits
pendant la crise sanitaire par les
postiers eux-mêmes n'y a aucune
reconnaissance qui est aujourd'hui
portée et en plus il ya avec le nouvel
actionnaire une politique d'accélération
de la privatisation de la poste
il faut dire que les postiers se sont
investis comme beaucoup de professions
durant la crise
on leur a chamboulé leurs horaires on
les a exposés ils ont rendu toujours le
service public et au final la
reconnaissance 0 ils n'ont pas eu les
différentes primes ont été remises en
cause voire complètement supprimée
sujettes au présentéisme avec les
difficultés liées à la crise sanitaire
voilà c'est presque 1000 euros de
pouvoir d'achat que les postiers ont
perdu sur l'année
et ces manifestants ici ils sont en
colère puisque ils ont perdu leurs
primes d'intéressement alors que le
groupe connaît un bénéfice important
pour 2020 2 milliard cent millions
d'euros contre 822 millions en 2019 donc
incompréhensible pour ses salariés alors
ils attendent un des réponses de la part
de la direction de la poste et en cas de
refus un sur l'essentiel de leurs
revendications ils comptent poursuivre
leur mouvement et déambuler organiser
d'autres manifestations dans les
semaines à venir
merci beaucoup nadège abderrazak pour
toutes ces précisions